- [Zach] Taking it back, it's
either 100 live on a Sunday
or percentage is 10,000
for a video conference
at 11:30 in the morning on a Sunday.
- Pass.
- [Male] Got it.
(upbeat music)
- You got your perspective.
Jason, big shout out to you brother,
doing a great job.
Tag yourself in here right now.
They need to know you're part of the fam.
Just did a hacking session,
you're gonna have to bounce around that
'cause there might be one or two things.
When you start seeing
creative, that's contextual,
to psychodemographics
against proxies that are business.
Right, it's alright, that
was for affect, good shit.
I like where you're going.
Man if I wasn't here after that,
that would've been a hit.
Now going to a doctor's appointment,
then I'm flying to Alabama
for the Senior Bowl
VaynerSports is kicking off.
Going down there to see
our guy Tyree Jackson,
quarterback from the University of Buffalo
that we're excited about.
Big shout out to AJ and
the rest of the team.
Super excited about Atlanta
next week, Super Bowl,
our Super Bowl party, our meet and greet.
Let's link that up as well.
What can I drop here knowing that this is,
you're leaving after this right?
- [Jason] I'm gonna stick
around for the dermatologist
and I'm gonna do the
car ride to the airport.
- Okay yeah.
So either now or for the car ride.
What can I do in a two
or three minute rant
that will bring the
most value to everybody?
Look I guess like synthesizing
the last three years,
this is an inside your head game.
At some point, eventually
a piece of content I make
is gonna break through,
maybe it's this one,
maybe it's this moment,
that the outside voices,
the outside structure,
these are forces that you
don't have control over.
So dwelling about your mom or your dad
or your boss or the economy
or somebody who left a comment
it's just not gonna work,
it's just not.
This is an insular game
the quieter it gets in your head.
And if you get the framework,
and I'm very up here, mentality, mindset,
and then I'm very tactical.
If you really break me down, it down,
watch me do what I do, not what I say,
watch what I do, not what I'm saying,
even though they align,
it's like first, look,
if you're perfect at Instagram
ads and influencer ads
and make the best shoes
and all these things,
by the way, if the shoes come in,
you're gonna have to blur 'em out,
blur 'em out again, blur.
You're gonna have to understand
that unless this is right,
if you're perfect at
execution, you're gonna lose.
This is why people on Wall Street,
or athletes or celebrities crush,
they make money, they get fame
but then they burn out, they die,
they go into depression, they're on drugs
'cause this wasn't right.
So for me, so much of
what I'm trying to do
is get you not to keep
up with the Joneses,
not worry about what your parents think,
don't think that money brings
you happiness, all this stuff.
And then every time somebody
becomes cynical and go,
easy for you to say,
I'm like, yo, you didn't
know me bro when I was 19.
Go hit up Rob Muse, go
hit up Robbie Turnitt,
go hit up Marisa Bird, go
hit up Randall Wernicke
go hit up people when I didn't have.
Go hit up people when I didn't have.
It was optimism, it was
optimism, it was optimism,
it was don't give a fuck
about what somebody says.
Once you go there, you go fast.
You do, you make it.
Once you get out of your own head,
you just go, you go fast.
- Right, what about now?
- It's so easy, right.
For me, I don't care about the money,
I care about my game, the process.
And those are the happiest people,
whether you are making financial success
or whether you're making $42,000 a year
being a farmer and you
love growing pumpkins,
you've won life.
The amount of people that
make way more money than me
but hate the process
are not luckier than me,
are not more fortunate than me.
Happiness has to be the ROI.
Happiness has to be
what everybody achieves.
And it's an evolution.
All three of us in this car right now
are doing different things
than we used to be doing,
different things make
you happy, dadadadada,
I could be unhappy
tomorrow and I'll change.
Happiness is what I chase.
I chase happiness.
What keeps me going is
I love what I'm doing.
I'd do it for free.
I would, this is me playing, I'm playing.
- [Jason] I get it.
- I know you get it
because anybody whose
creative really gets it.
Starving artists are real, that's real.
And I feel far more similar
to a starving artist
than I do to a hedge fund Wall Street gal
because I feel like a lot
of people in that world
are unbelievably,
and not everybody, but a lot
of people are driven by money.
I don't know how people don't get it.
Well I do.
When you don't have
something, you envy it.
When somebody's super attractive,
they take it for granted.
Right Avi?
You take your super
attractiveness for granted?
But really, if you're a 10, guy or girl,
you don't even understand for people
who can't get anybody they want or get,
there's so many privileges,
whether you're smart,
whether you do math well,
whether you don't have anxiety,
whether you're attractive,
whether you have money,
whether you don't have money
and you love the grind.
There's unlimited amounts of
privileges and adversities,
it just comes down to perspective.
I think growing up with nothing
was the greatest thing
that ever happened to me.
Other people till at 53 are complaining
that's why they weren't successful.
They lack accountability.
- Yes.
- Right, by the way,
it's funny that we're
talking about 100 grand
so much in this vlog,
I've said in talks and
maybe you can find it
to clip in here,
that was my number too.
That was the only number
I wanted to get to, 100,
that seemed big.
By the way, 100 and you're
living $130,000 lifestyle sucks.
42 and living a $20,000
lifestyle is amazing.
There's other variables
besides how much you make.
Anybody who runs a business knows
it's the profit at the end.
To me in life, the profit at the end
is the happiness radar.
If you're making 100
but you decided to move
into a neighborhood
where you're keeping up with the Joneses
and everybody else is
more like a 200 family
and you're just trying to keep up
versus going to a
neighborhood where it's 80
and big fish, small,
there's so many things.
Do you need clothes to say you're cool?
Do you feel bad?
Some parents are crushed
when their kids can't go to Disney World
like everybody else.
There parents see that as
the chip on the shoulder
that the kids gonna use.
It all is perspective.
What keeps me going is
life, happiness is the ROI.
(upbeat music)
- [Zach] It's either 100 live on a Sunday
or the percentage is 10,000
for a video conference
at 11:30 in the morning on a Sunday.
- Pass.
- [Zach] Got it.
So then in Brazil,
I know Brazil's key for youi
so I'm trying to see what I can do.
I have another group
that's coming to the table
but we have 100 grand November 8
which is a Friday,
but a pretty large event,
it's about 13,000 people.
- The big issue there
is I have to be back for the Jets game.
- [Zach] Right, so it's a Friday.
So we should be able to
get you back no problem
but I don't know if at 100 grand--
- The money's not exciting
but the size and the market is exciting.
You think you could push them?
- [Zach] I don't know if
I could push them too much
but what I think I can do
is I think I can buy us some time,
talk to this other group,
see if I can get an offer from them
and see if we can weigh the
two of them against each other
then you can leverage
them against each other.
- Okay and I'm willing to discount
to like 135 potentially on the other one
but let's buy some time.
Cool, thanks brother, talk to you.
Alright bye bye.
You can use that whole thing, that's cool.
Avi, you got freaked out by that?
- I did.
- I love it.
You mean on the how
quick I'm just like pass?
I didn't make $100,000 a year
when I was 31 one years old, a year.
I keep talking about patience.
I didn't make that in a year.
- [Avi] Now he's turning it down.
- For a day, for a speech.
- [Jason] It's time.
- Time.
So at 30, I started Wine Library TV,
YouTube blows up.
At 31, I'm on Conan O'Brien, Ellen,
there's articles being written about me.
Now they're writing that the business grew
from three to $60 million in sales.
I'm becoming this guy.
I got so many God damn emails
from friends in high school
during that period when I was showing up
in all these magazines and TV shows
and every single one of them was like,
hey Gary, do you remember
me from high school?
Oh my God, you're so lucky.
I wrote back every single
one of them and said,
let me just clarify one thing,
I am not lucky, I worked.
I worked every God damn weekend
and every holiday since
I was 14 years old.
So you can keep that
luck shit in your pocket.
(upbeat music)